the health district is now offering
second doses of the copic 19 vaccine at
cashman center
now compared to last week people say
they're getting their vaccines pretty
quickly
joe moeller is there live tonight with
more on some of the changes joe
well here at the convention center
people were waiting in some lines but
nothing like we saw last week when
people are waiting up to
four hours well now with cashman now
offering the second dose people are
hoping they can get their second dose
on time easy it was great
to help get more people done with the
vaccination the health district is now
opening cashman center for the last dose
i called this morning
they said they had an appointment at 11
a.m i came down i was in and out in 20
minutes
we spoke to a few people including bill
vickers who says they were done within a
half an hour
he was happy to know cashman opened
after having a hard time booking online
showing me every day full and so i was
going to run out of time because you
have to take your second dose within
42 days last week the convention center
had some lines lasting up to four hours
tuesday people were still waiting but
not as long i was kind of surprised when
i got here
10 30 to see the line as long as it was
so it took me about an hour and a half
to get through
i got here before 11 so
took me at least 45 minutes now people
are urged to make the appointments on
the date they were given or soon after
that
if you made multiple appointments you
were being asked to cancel using the
link you were sent by the health
district
many still are having a difficult time
booking online vickers says
another way worked to get him in same
day call
call the helpline
you know back out here live we do want
to remind people that there are no more
walk-ins happening here at the
convention center and also
there are some changes happening at
cashman as well that has been the site
for copen 19 testing starting on friday
they will no longer be doing the testing
they're at that site they'll be
expanding at other locations
reporting live at the convention center
joe mullen 8 news now